[Music]
welcome back
so this is going to be a really fun
lecture we are going to talk about how
we can
start to solve one of the hardest
problems in computational science the
problem of turbulence modeling
or turbulence closure modeling using
modern techniques in deep learning
or deep neural networks okay so i'm
going to jump right in
direct numerical simulation of the fluid
flow equations the navy or stokes
equations
is a pretty powerful tool and with
moore's law with faster and faster
computers we're able to do really
remarkable things
so this is a simulation that took 35
million
cpu hours and this is a segment
of a wing so just a small piece of a
wing and this is the full direct
numerical simulation of the
navier-stokes equations absolutely
stunning detail at all spatial and
temporal scales of what's happening
in this unsteady turbulent flow over a
wing
so this is what we want to do this is
like the holy grail
is to model all of the scales in space
and time
but we know that for real engineering
flows of interest we're unable to do
that
and so what we need to do is approximate
how these turbulent fluctuations
that we don't want to model or we can't
afford to model how they affect the big
average quantities of interest like
what's the lift and the drag
and where is the separation point going
to happen on this airfoil
okay and so that's the problem of
closure modeling in general
is that even with moore's law of
exponentially growing computer power
it will take forever you know hundreds
a hundred years or more to be able to
simulate these flows we really care
about at full scale fast enough for them
to be useful for real-time
control for optimization and design okay
and so that's where turbulence modeling
comes in we want to form
models of the turbulence so we don't
have to simulate all of those turbulent
scales
and this field is rapidly advancing
every year
there are breakthrough results in
turbulence modeling now
using deep learning and machine learning
so i'm going to walk you through just a
few
key pieces of work to get you excited
about
what's happening in the field and how
you might be able to jump in and
contribute
so there is a fantastic review paper
that was written
i believe in 2019 by durasami
yakirito and xiao all three of
whom are expert turbulence modelers
themselves and who have made
key advances to this field of turbulence
modeling with machine learning with
neural networks
and there's a lot of really really good
papers on this
now turbulence modeling you can break up
into a couple of key
kind of groupings there's rand's
equations or the reynolds average navy
or stokes
which essentially tries to model average
quantities of your flow the mean lift
the mean drag
things like that and then large eddy
simulations
which are more expensive and higher
fidelity
they're trying to get these unsteady uh
kind of movies or simulations of your
flow
but on a coarser grid then you could uh
you know you can't simulate all scales
so you're going to course in your grid
and simulate the big scales
and so we're going to jump into how
neural networks and machine learning are
being used in these kind of two big
categories
uh we talked about this a little bit in
the review paper we wrote uh myself
barrett nowak and petrus kumitsakis the
following year also an annual review of
fluid mechanics
so kind of both of those have some
references of interest
okay i'm going to just give you a very
very brief
recap of the reynolds average
navier-stokes equations
the whole idea the big idea here is that
you have your navy or stokes equations
in this case the incompressible
navier-stokes equations
those are essentially representing
conservation of mass
and momentum so mass conservation
momentum conservation
and you take your flow field of interest
your velocity field u
which is a function of of space and time
and you're going to split it into an
average component you bar
this does not vary in time it's just
your mean flow
and all of the turbulent fluctuations
you prime all of the little stuff that's
happening
in time and if you take this uh
reynolds decomposition and plug it into
your navy or stokes equations you can
get some kind of
bulk equations for the mean flow
variables for these barred
u bar variables but those bulk equations
always have these pesky terms called the
reynold stresses
which depend on those turbulent
fluctuations which we would rather not
model we would rather
not simulate those we want to just
account for their effect
on the big scales and you bar and so the
whole closure problem as far as rands is
concerned
is trying to uh you know it's this issue
that the mean flow depends on those
turbulent fluctuations
so we're essentially going to try to
model those turbulent fluctuations
in terms of mean flow variables and this
is
by construction by necessity that is an
approximation
these reynold stresses depend on small
turbulent scales that we don't want to
resolve
and so we're going to approximate these
in terms of larger bulk variables that
we do want
to model and to measure okay and so
that's the closure problem for rands
similarly the closure problem for large
eddy simulations
and this is again proposed by
smagarinsky in
1963 is that we have some
high reynolds number very very
complicated turbulent flow
what we're going to do is we're going to
try to simulate it on a coarser
grid so instead of all of this
resolution which would be very expensive
to simulate
we're going to simulate these unsteady
time evolving navy or stokes equations
on this coarser grid
by low-pass filtering the equations up
here
and then trying to understand what
happens uh in these kind of very very
small scales smaller than these boxes
what's happening inside these course
boxes we're going to model how those
affect the physics and so
essentially the entire les closure
problem amounts to the fact
that there is non-linear coupling
between the small scales and the big
scales through
convection and that non-linearity makes
it so that we
need to take into account the tiniest
scales even when we
simulate this kind of course resolution
simulation here and so this is called
sub grid scale modeling or
sgs models where i need a little model
for every single one of these course
boxes of what's happening under the hood
what the little turbulent fluctuations
are doing
to these large-scale navy or stokes
equations okay those are the kind of
big rands and les turbulence problems
now we're going to jump in
you know to some specific examples and
again
this idea of being able to throw away
the small scales the idea is that those
those really fast turbulent fluctuations
typically happen on
small spatial scales they're really
small vortices
that are that are interacting and
the smallest scales and turbulence often
act to dissipate energy
much like viscous diffusion in the
regular navier-stokes equations
so essentially what we're going to do is
chop off
these really high frequency or small
scale
terms and just approximate those as if
they were an effective
viscosity that's called an effective
viscosity model or an eddy viscosity
model
and we can use that for rans and for les
okay so in rans again our closure
problem
one of my absolute favorite papers that
uses deep
learning to start start to solve these
uh rand's closure modeling
problems is this paper by julia ling
andrew kurzowski and jeremy templeton
so let me just go back here to this
rand's equation
there are lots of approximations for
these reynolds stresses
in terms of bulk quantities in the flow
these eddy viscosity models
there is the prandtl mixing layer hype
mixing length hypo
hypothesis there are k epsilon 2
equation models k
omega models there's the uh spellart
alsmorand models all of them have kind
of known
deficiencies for certain classes of
separated flows
and so this paper by ling at all
uses neural networks to get better
models
for how those rental stresses depend on
the large scale
mean flows mean flow structures and one
of the things i love about this paper
is that they went back to the literature
back to 1975 to this
uh and this is the architecture they use
so they're going to use
this custom architecture that is
designed to be physical
i'll tell you about this in a little bit
but they went
back to the literature from 1975 before
uh you know we had these super computers
and deep learning
anything so there's this great paper by
pope 1975
where essentially he develops
a better eddie viscosity model or
effective viscosity hypothesis
and i want to walk you through this
because this is going to help you
understand
why ling at all's work is so interesting
and so relevant because what they do
they don't just build a deep neural
network
uh end to end they build a custom neural
network
that incorporates some of these better
effective viscosity hypothesis modeling
into it so they went back to 1975
figured out what these models have to
have like what structure they have to
have
and built that into their deep learning
approach okay i'm not going to read
every word but i just want to
walk through this very briefly this is
the pope paper
uh okay so this is we've already talked
about this in the last
video so the first effective viscosity
hypothesis
was business 1877 which basically
says these turbulent reynold stresses
can be modeled as some effective
viscosity
times things that depend on the bulk
flow kind of these average
barred quantities you bar and here
subscript 1 2 means
partial big u partial y i believe
plus partial big v partial x okay
something like that
good so the business hypothesis fails
for boundary layers over curved surfaces
and so there's things you can do to fix
that okay and this is basically the
uh the generalized boost and s
hypothesis for
three component flow good um
and then the approach taken in this pope
paper
is uh built on this work by lumley 1970
and lumley is one of the giants of
reduced order modeling
pod proper orthogonal decomposition
coherent structure modeling
a lot of my work you know 50 years later
is built on
on the stuff that lumlee did in the 70s
but i just love this this paragraph i
wanted
to you know to bring this up to you so
this is based
on lumley 1970 but let's read this last
sentence
in forming the tensor polynomial lumley
1970 made
illicit use of the alternating tensor
density
and so the result and some of the
conclusions based upon it were incorrect
illicit so lumley was into like breaking
bad
type uh turbulence modeling here he made
illicit use
of the alternating tensor density and
that's one of the things that pope is
going to fix in this paper
okay so uh the pope paper again
we're going to bring this back to deep
learning this is going to guide how we
build our neural network or how ling at
all built their neural network
so just like these k epsilon
two equation turbulence models i told
you about where k is the turbulent
kinetic energy
and epsilon is the rate of dissipation
of the turbulent kinetic energy
that's the k and epsilon here you can
essentially use those
to get these three quantities of
interest here
a are these kind of normalized reynold
stresses
and s and omega are the symmetric and
anti-symmetric uh tensors that
essentially
will help us to model this this a
quantity that we want to model
we want to model a just in terms of
these bulk flow quantities
big u's okay good and so mathematically
after a decent bit of math
what we find is that there are
ten tensors and five invariants or five
conserved quantities
that pop out of this modeling framework
and so
um these are the ten tensors that depend
on that s
and that w that we're trying to model
and these are the five uh invariants
that have to be invariant
for any turbulent closure model
that is built on this theory and so
the long story short you can model
your reynold stresses in a this is the
thing we want to model in terms of those
bulk quantities
in terms of a sum of those 10 tensors in
big t
these 10 tensors here that you can
compute
and so this is where uh ling at all you
know you fast forward
almost almost 50 years 45 years
i guess 40 this paper is 2016 ling at
all
fast forward 40 years and we are going
to
find what combination of these tensors t
add up to form the reynold stresses
using a deep neural network
okay so that's really the the name of
the game there's this
really rigorous mathematical
justification for why
a generic a general rans model should
take
this form where there are ten kind of
basis tensors
that you're going to add up in a special
combination
to get your reynolds stresses and this
might
vary in space and in time depending on
different properties of the bulk flow
and so what ling at all did was
essentially
model and i want to go back to that
neural network picture
they essentially instead of just
building a big deep neural network which
is what you might have done if you were
naive
they built this custom physics informed
neural network structure that has an
invariant input layer and this kind of
tensor layer
times these coefficients so that by
construction
the the network that they
have designed the turbulence model that
pops out
satisfies those five invariants it's
galilean and variant it satisfies
the basic physics that has to be
satisfied uh for a valid rans model
and so i love it because they have
actually built in the physics
by looking back 40 years you know to a
really seminal paper by pope
and so if you look at their results you
find it's a little hard to see i think
this is a pretty high resolution
picture so if you zoom in you can see
this this is basically flow
over a dip that will separate so there's
going to be separated flow so here's the
true direct numerical simulation
and you see that there's this kind of
separation bubble here as the flow
separates and reattaches now we know
that that's really hard for rand's
models this kind of
linear effective viscosity and quadratic
effective viscosity models
just don't have that separation bubble
but their
kind of tensor basis neural network that
is this custom physics-informed neural
network i showed you
if you look it does have a small
separated bubble
right there now it's not exactly the
right size
but in principle this gives you better
predictions
because we are respecting the known
physics and so this was you know a paper
from 2016
in the last five years there's been a
lot of progress so making this kind of
more production ready uh and you know
bigger
better training data to train these
these neural networks
okay good so that's one of my kind of
favorite papers in the field for rand's
modeling
now if we go to large eddy simulations
there have been some really interesting
works
using neural networks and deep learning
for les as well
okay um and so i'm just going to show
you a couple of these
one of my favorites is uh this paper by
roman malik omer sen and
their colleagues again 2019 jfm
they're using deep neural networks to
model what the subgrid scale physics
how that's impacting uh kind of these
large-scale navier-stokes equations
and so they have built this kind of
custom neural network again where
they're putting in physical quantities
of interest
they have a deep learning architecture
and what pops out
is this term that is needed to close the
subgrid scale modeling problem this kind
of pi
tilde i'm not going to tell you exactly
what that means you can go read their
paper
but they get very very nice large eddy
simulation models that are closed
not by using these kind of heuristic by
hand physics closure models
but by kind of a learned a deep learned
closure model so they train it on high
fidelity direct numerical simulations
where they know the truth
and in principle they can learn better
closure models for how the subgrid scale
physics affects the larger scales so
really cool paper i really like this one
a lot i encourage you to read it
they're doing tons of great stuff since
then
another really interesting paper and i
talked about this in my lecture on deep
reinforcement learning
is this work by uh novati kumitsakis
and their colleagues where essentially
what they've done
is used a multi-agent reinforcement
learning
approach to the same les subgrid scale
modeling
so here is a fluid flow simulation on a
very very fine mesh where lots of you
know it's resolving all of the physics
what they do is they try to massively
coarsen the grid to just these blue
points
and then they learn kind of using this
multi-agent reinforcement learning they
learn the interactions
that would capture and resolve the
physics
that's happening kind of at all these
red squares that are being
under-resolved
if you just use blue squares on a coarse
grid
very cool idea this just came out in
nature machine
intelligence and they've shown i mean
i'm showing you a couple of pictures
here they have
really really nice plots showing kind of
the convergence of statistics
of these simulations using this learning
approach so really
interesting uh kind of accurate and
generalizable
approach to les with again deep uh
reinforcement learning
and this just is kind of some of the
pictures from from their paper that i
really liked
where they show kind of flow field
structures
i believe the second row is the les kind
of these large eddy simulations
at a course resolution and then these
are the smagorinsky coefficients
below so again if you really want to
know kind of quantitatively
how well this is doing you should go
check out their paper where they have
these very
nice quantitative scaling plots of
you know accuracy versus resolution and
things like that
okay good the last point i want to make
in this discussion about how deep
learning can be used for closure
modeling
is that a lot of this is actually very
closely related to super resolution in
image sciences
so what we're essentially trying to do
is
infer what's happening under the under
the
hood or behind the scenes of this course
simulation
so that we know how these course boxes
are interacting with each other
and we can resolve the effect of the
fine scale physics that's inside
so underneath this course resolution
there's all of this micro scale physics
happening
just like underneath this course image
there are eyelashes and a cornea
how do we account for those effects you
know in the model
and so if we can have better
super resolution algorithms so if we can
infer
what the fine resolution is just from
the course resolution and its neighbors
we can use that information in these
closure models
and there's some really interesting work
on this ben erickson
has done some great work on um super
resolution
using uh neural networks sam tyra and
colleagues from ucla have also done
really nice work on
kind of deep super resolution in fluids
and there's also a ton of work in the
atmospheric and ocean sciences community
so climate science and weather
scientists
have some of the biggest fluid problems
around right their reynolds number
are earth scale reynolds numbers and so
they're also very interested in these
les
and super resolution techniques and how
they can build those into their
climate models okay so with that
i think i would like to conclude and
just you know
i hope i've gotten you excited this is
one of the most important problems
if you want to do any large-scale
engineering or science involving a fluid
chances are you're going to be modeling
the turbulence instead of resolving all
of those scales
and in the modern era there are some
really powerful emerging techniques in
deep learning that are helping us do a
better job
of modeling the turbulence i will point
out
my personal philosophy is very much like
the ling at all philosophy
the more physics you can bake in the
more you can make your deep
learning physical by construction the
better of a job you're going to be able
to do
when you use it for physical modeling
all right thank you